aux côtés du comité vérité et justice
pour adama ce samedi dans les rues de
beaumont sur oise
plusieurs militants écologistes c'est la
première fois depuis la mort du jeune
homme qu'alternative à un mouvement
citoyen engagé dans la lutte pour le
climat appelle à une mobilisation
commune un soutien salutaire estima ça
traoré la third à damas celle qui est
devenue la figure de proue de la lutte
contre les violences policières en
france tient tout de même à assurer que
son comité reste indépendant aujourd'hui
sur un rassemblement qui a été organisée
par le comité à ma seule on a réaffirmé
encore une fois notre indépendance par
contre on salue le climat génération
climat de dénoncer les violences
policières et d'être là aujourd'hui dans
les rues de beaumont
cette mobilisation commune c'est aussi
l'occasion pour le comité vérité et
justice pour adama d'élargir sa base une
convergence des luttes qu'appellent de
leurs voeux plusieurs militants
antiracistes
objectif faire front commun contre les
violences policières dans ces mouvements
là il est important de ne pas
saucissonner les causes mais faire en
sorte qu'on se retrouve tous sur un truc
qui est basique à savoir que la peine de
mort est abolie en france et qu'il est
hors de question qu'on laisse des jeunes
se faire tuer par la prison de pays pour
faire résonner cette convergence
certains manifestants ont opté pour ce
slogan génération à damas génération
climat on veut respirer
c'est un message qui est très simple et
qui peut-être est aussi très
révolutionnaire et on veut respirer à la
fois et bien dans les quartiers ou ne
veut pas on veut que personne ne souffre
de violence policière et d'une mère de
ces violences policières
on veut aussi que bon
personne on veut avoir que chacun et
chacune et la possibilité de s'exprimer
dans l'espace public donc de pouvoir
manifester de pouvoir se rassembler que
nos libertés fondamentales sont
respectées outre les militants
écologistes et anti racistes des élus de
gauche et des ong comme la ligue des
droits de l'homme ont également répondu
à l'appel